[Music]  Jennifer Lopez and Alex Rodriguez's  romance appears to be heating up  absolutely passionate about everything  that I get involved with JLo hit the  town with her new beau a rod for a  romantic date in Miami the couple was  spotted enjoying an intimate dinner for  two at Casa tua Restaurant Thursday  night here's the singer showing off her  toned legs in a sexy white mini dress  with a daring slid while the former New  York Yankee star matched her in white  pants and a navy sweater from couples  workout sessions to their Bahamas trip  the pair has been spending a lot of  quality time together though a source  tells et their relationship is still  very new JLo's eggs beau Casper Smart  also told us he's happy for her new  romance and says he and his ex have  nothing but respect and love for each  other  he's just been super loving and  supportive  [Music]  you